have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information
has been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-0
but from accessing the meeting should
call
271-3600 or email
hcs ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
assisting us this
this morning jennifer four is our
committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there's anyone
in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
representative cordelli here in the
committee room
representative here in the committee
room representative
here in the committee room
representative
here at home in hudson new hampshire my
representative moffitt in in the
committee room with eight others
representative robson here in the
committee room in concord
representative andres here home alone
in salisbury senator board
here in the committee room
representative
here on this video representative miler
you're in contouck in my home office
representative luna
here representative shaw here in the
community room
representative cornell here home alone
in manchester
representative tanner uh here in
georgia's mills sunapee with my
uh rescue dog raven who may bark
representative ellison here in concord
i'm having a new roof put on my house
today so there's gonna i'm gonna stay on
mute as much as possible i already have
a pounding headache after an hour of
this
yeah i know that feeling maybe a couple
people walking through during the
session
she's tested represented play
i am here i'm in my office in bow new
hampshire
here in the center conway new hampshire
with my dog who definitely will bark
that black and i'm here in the lobby
i have to commend this committee for
we are very good attendants well thank
you to everybody for that
uh going on here uh we have uh
four bills on the dock we have two
zero two two zero three uh
388 and 255
um those are to be exact uh
next thursday we also have four bills
that are coming up
uh to be heard that coming over from the
senate i believe we also have
another bill which has been sent to us
so we won't
that will be a later item though
i would encourage everybody be looking
at those bills for thursday
look them over um if we're able to get
through some of the hearing
on those we may get and we most likely
will try to exact
some the last bill which we have set for
on thursday is a finance bill
or a bill which deals with funding of
schools
uh we may want to really look at that
seriously
and and and get it moving it looks back
at the previous year for
setting the enrollment for the funding
of the next year
rather than using the enrollment of the
pandemic year we're in right now
uh serious issue so look that over
please and be wise that if we can
move some of that along in terms of i
know contracts are
our districts are in the process this
spring of making contracts with
personnel
um they're knowing or understanding
where
you know how the budgets can be promised
it would be helpful to them so
i i hope we can uh address some of that
on on thursday
yes yeah on on senate bill 135
i do plan on introducing two amendments
um
on that during the hearing uh
particularly because they're relevant to
the work that we did last session with
respect to the
um the equitable fiscal disparity and
free and reduced price uh price lunch
grants
and um and i think that will help us
move the um move the school
funding towards more like what what we
saw in
fy 21 which is which is
closes the gap from where this bill
leaves it
okay if you have those amendments
prepared represent luna
you know could you distribute those no
absolutely i'll get those to you as soon
as i have them thank you
okay so with that mr chair personal
privilege please
go ahead uh yeah i just uh as before we
get started here i'd just like to
make a note that today is the golden
anniversary
of the passage of the 26th amendment
now since we all know about the
amendments of the u.s constitution we
know that that's the 18 year old vote
and 25 50 years ago
i was involved in the creation of the
youth franchise coalition in washington
dc
which was the group that basically
brought together various organizations
that helped lay the foundation for the
passage of this
particular piece of legislation so i'm
proud of that legacy and i just wanted
to share that with the committee because
i think it was in
there's only two constitutional
amendments
that were that emanated from the
grassroots
that was the 19th amendment which was
the you the
woman suffrage and the youth vote which
was the 26th amendment so i just wanted
to make that and celebrate that
with the committee today you know
thank you very much mel uh does anybody
know the colors of the
woman's suffrage what were the colors
white purple and gold purple and yellow
purple and gold yep and white
okay now we've got our our important
facts done and i appreciate it all it's
uh
it's good to know that if you're going
to be in the military at age 18 you can
vote
right als also i'm not sure the
committee is aware of it or not but the
con val decision was rendered today and
it was basically remanded back
to the original court which means they
start all over again
and i think rick much of the work that
we worked on the school funding
commission last summer
will become foundational to that
particular case as it goes forward
yeah only the attorneys know okay
so we're going to go on into our uh
job for today where the first bill we're
going to address is the 202 bill
so we can turn the pages to twenty
okay i recognize represent leon for a
motion
thank you mr chair i would like to move
house bill 202 and expedient legislate
and representative hobson second that
okay so we have a motion on the table to
itl uh hsb202 represent leon would you
like to speak to your motion
yes please thank you mr chair uh this is
a very well-meaning bill
however we're actually in luck um we
have an email that came from
um that was forwarded by jennifer for at
50 this morning with information from
the department of education
um there is already an rsa rsa 189
11a which prohibits the public
identification or stigmatization of
students who cannot pay for a
meal or who owe a debt the prohibition
um the the issue of prohibiting a child
who cannot pay for a meal or who owes a
meal debt from doing chores or other
work to
pay for meals unless chores or other
worker required for all students
are already prohibited by usda
regulatory
4330-2 so that's already taken care of
then as far as communicating anything to
the parents instead of the children
is also covered in federal guidelines
and if we look at this
there have not been any issues uh
there's already
clear language on that communication in
the cfr and also in some of the other
roles that are there
this is something that definitely is
near and dear to my heart as somebody
who was a reduced lunch kid
and i'm very happy to know that this is
already in there and if there's any
problems we just need to make sure that
they are addressed with these existing
regulations
thank you reps and hobson do you have
any ad oh no i was just thank erica
for all of her hard work from that
opening
thank you so it's open to discussion at
this time
from the committee represent milor
uh thank you mr chair we had a long
discussion around this and
representative mullen
did have a lengthy conversation with the
department about this
and basically found the information that
was submitted to us this morning
uh and uh we will be uh uh supporting
the itl motion
yeah i i was gonna ask the question uh i
gave this to jennifer ford to get
out to folks this morning so did you
receive a
sir oh so we don't have representative
mullen back yet
but you're saying you're in support of
it so i guess that with that i
out there i actually can still i have
the tv on
youtube in the other room and i can
actually still hear her testifying
okay uh you know i i'd like to
i'd like to have everybody present you
know i hate to see somebody not
able to to vote on something if they're
engaged with another committee due to
covet
um there's so much uh representative
milo you're the ranking
uh uh uh representative on on the
democratic side here
um i i would say go ahead with the vote
okay
thank you okay okay madam clerk can you
please call the
vote please yes this is itl
house bill 202. representative cordelli
yes lieutenant paul yes representative
allard
yes representative yes representative
moffitt
yes hobson yes representative andres
yes representative board yes
representative yes representative yes
president miler yes that it will know
yes presenter shaw yes representative
cornell
yes and can i just say i just got a text
from
a representative mullen that she'll be
here in a minute i'll call her last
okay representative tanner
yes representative ellison
yes representative lay
yes
yes uh representative mullen are you
[Laughter]
representative shaw yes thank you
and representative yes
20-0 20-0
um good with conspiracy yes yes
well that was easy that was very easy a
lot easier than that
huh well i i apologize mr chair for my
tardiness but
i was the last bill so once we started
in there was no
turning back well i see you were
a little late because we had another
representative here took a lot of time
on his bill
excellent thank you representative
whatever that means okay uh go on
like upload more okay that's pretty good
problem
two zero three this is a bill
establishing a committee to study school
meal programs in new hampshire public
schools
and non-secretariat schools that accept
public funds
uh
representative allard for motion thank
you mr chair i would move
that house bill 203 the ito
i'll second represent leon second set
prep salary like to speak to your motion
yes thank you mr chair just briefly
school meals programs have been
instituted and evolving since the 1930s
in new hampshire they have been studied
six ways to sunday uh and
this this particular bill in light of
202 being itl
this bill becomes superfluous so
great volume of superfluous bills
in the state of new hampshire i would
suggest we withdraw it
do you have anything to add uh no i
think that that's whatsoever
perhaps that mullen i'll jump right in
here thank you mr chairman
um poor sherry white i'm sure that she
uh
is has had enough of house education
because
i understand that representative leon
spent some time with her
uh gathering information about school
lunches perhaps
i don't know but uh i spent an hour with
her last week
and um while i concur
that we it'll the previous bill
because the three points that
representative oregon needed to make had
already been made
my conversation with sherry white really
revealed the fact that we still have
unanswered questions about the
difference between the federal
regulations the state level regulations
and the local regulations
it seems to me that in my discussion
with her
we talked about the fact that local
school boards
develop their own lunch charging
policies
and that they vary from school to school
she indicated to me that she has some
private schools that do in fact
participate in the usda program and some
public schools that don't
that have privatized their programs uh
and also that there are differences in
regulation between federal state and
local
statutes so i i um
i i would like to recommend that we go
ahead with the study committee
if for no other reason than to develop
a list of specific questions to be
answered
i don't think we need to reinvent the
wheel but
we had a lot of discussion the last time
around about no children going hungry
and my apologies again for not being
here for the discussion on 202 but
the federal regulations say that we only
have to provide a safety net k-3
grades k through three and uh
there are a lot of kids grades four
through 12
who may in fact need some sort of
clarification or intervention
on what happens if you're hungry at
school and you're
not a free and reduced lunch student
because if you're a free and reduced
lunch student you're okay
but if you're not then at the moment
middle school and high school
kids don't get fed if their accounts are
in arrears if their local
school board has that as the charging
policy
so i i i will stop there
and not talk for an hour but say that i
would
um i would encourage that we move
forward with the study committee
further discussion represent tanner
uh thank you mr chair can you hear me
okay yes
um so i have uh two observations
on this one is that um in newport
there's a
there's a group who actually do backpack
uh meals for the kids um for weekends
and
and school holidays and
other times when they go without food
and there's also the issue that
during this pandemic schools have become
the center for people to get food
and a lot of people have moved uh from
being kind of on the edge to maybe being
to the point where they now
could uh qualify for free and reduced
hot lunch um
but i think that because of that because
we see
i i mean you see the overwhelming
numbers of kids
now getting lunches uh and
actually being fed i think it's
something that
as a state we need to address
particularly
with representative mullen's uh insight
that the
state regulations and the federal
regulations and the local regulations
i think we need to come up with some
directives
if not anything else and i i don't think
it would be
um a major lift to have a committee
on this to study it for next year thank
you
is it possible for the department of
education
with uh miss white uh form a group over
there to do
exactly what you were just talking about
representative owens
i wish i could answer that question for
you representative i don't know
i certainly would be happy to
participate
in something like that but i i don't
know what
what ms white's intention was she did
know that we had a study
go ahead and represent um just you know
if we had our committee then certainly
we would
have uh sherry white and and people
uh that could come in and give us
information and give us some statistics
on what is actually happening in
new hampshire and i think that that uh
just adds one more
check to why we should have a committee
on this particular subject thank you
my only question there was do we need to
have a legislative committee do that
when the department has the capability
of putting a group together
to you know review and discuss uh the
the pluses and the minuses associated
with the uh
uh further further further represent
um thank you mr chair right now as an
economist i value data
and i'm sure that uh our others on this
committee do as well
uh right now our data wouldn't be very
good because we are we have waivers
where everybody's getting the free
lunches
um i know that this this seems like a
very intriguing area but right now this
isn't going to be comparable to what
happens on the other side of this
pandemic
so i think asking some questions and
just trying to get a better
understanding makes sense but right
now having a committee to review what's
happening when we're in the middle of an
unprecedented shift
isn't going to inform laws that we would
further discussion
representatives your hands still up or
okay thank you uh further further
questions from the
discussion not seeing any uh
mountain park would you please call the
roll
yes representative moffat yes
representative hobson yes
representative andres yes representative
yes representative ah sorry
representative leon yes representative
no representative blake no
yes
there will be a minority report and
representative mullen will do that one
the next bill we're going to move into
and i'd like to remind people that are
writing minority and majority reports
please get those in we're trying to get
these done now as quickly as we can
for lindsay to get into the upcoming
session on the seventh eighth and the
ninth
okay going to the next bill 388 that's
the memphis education
hardship bill represent cordelli
thank you mr chairman i would like to
ought to pass on house bill
388 and also
offer amendments 0 9 2
represent hour do you have a second
the motion i second the motion yes thank
you very much
so we have a motion on the table uh
ought to pass
and have offered and promise uh
amendment 0932h
on manifest education hardship uh
representative cordelli
the amendment of 0.923
uh replaces all in the bill after the
actual applause
and uh clarifies issues that we had
originally with
the language and original bills
and uh so if you refer to
the amendment uh basically it
does several things uh in addition to
the best interest of the child
provisions as well as the manifest
education hardship
provisions it adds the ability
for a student to transfer to a public
school
public academy or an approved private
and you'll see that throughout the
in addition um
on page two at the top lines
four through seven you'll see
that if the student is reassigned to a
private school
that school may charge tuition to the
parent or may enter
into an agreement for tuition with the
ascending school district and that is
the same language
that is found in the existing
statute which is
should be on page 3 lines 22
proceeding on you'll see several more
areas where we added the
approved private school
uh in
on page four on lines nine
through thirteen uh or really that whole
section
day in current statute
uh it specifies that this
school district or public academy may
deny
but cannot base that decision on
the disability of a child
so we added in there that if a parent
believed that denial was based on a
disability
we referred to several provisions
uh for appeal that the department
consuming to the
state board that the parent would have
as well as their ability to file a
complaint with the human rights
commission both
going on on page four also you'll see
several
places where we remove non-sectarian
language in accordance with the
and again on the last page page
five we added in the uh single ability
for uh the
charging of tuition or a tuition
agreement with the
sending school district this is in
relation to a manifest education
hardship
case as opposed to the previous
place where we acted for the
best interests of students
section so that's
basically what the uh amendment does mr
sure
thank you very much representative
cordell you represent howard do you have
anything to add to that
uh no mr chairman i don't know thank you
uh open to discussion represent my work
thank you mr chairman uh i've got i have
major
uh issues with this uh first of all
we spent significant amount of time
last session dealing with the current
outline for manifest hardship we had a
subcommittee
we work with the school boards
association and we outlined that
that was just last year so this this
bill hasn't really been had a chance to
even be
implemented this year so i
i first question is seriousness
of radically changing this bill
after we had a lot of time a lot of
conversation
to form the current piece of statute
that we have
then mr chairman i've got a major
concern is because
the current the initial proposal
cited 193 colon
2 dash a
this bill refers to 93
colon 3. so it changes
the initial presentation of this bill
and i'm i i seriously question whether
this
amendment is appropriate because of its
change not only in the change in the
cited statute
but in the content of this amendment
and i would like to request the clerk
to clarify whether or not this is
germaine this bill is germaine
this amendment is germane to the initial
bill as proposed
because it seems to me that the the it's
a major change
and that a frankly a hearing
should be conducted on this amendment
before this committee act so i would
like to have
the clerk give a ruling on exactly the
status of this amendment as it relates
to his germaness
one and two whether or not the content
of this bill
would demand a public hearing on it
before we can
conclude it in executive session so i'd
like that request to be
uh dealt with the clerk first before we
thanks very much mr chair um i um
concur with everything representative
miler just um just said i think when we
when we heard the bill back on
march 4th it was really clear that the
um
that the language that um that
the bill was based on um was was not
currently in statute at all and had no
connection with the um with the
substantial work that this committee did
uh
two years ago with respect to manifest
educational hardship
and um and then further i think when you
take a look at um
at some of the some of the changes
that have now been uh suggested in the
amendment
based on uh finally based on
the the current statute so that's a
that's a huge improvement i'm not
i'm not uh you know denying that that at
least we're starting with current
statute
but but the changes for example on page
four the amendment lines nine through
thirteen
that that was never even contemplated in
the original
in the original bill and and now you're
actually
holding non-resident public school
districts
accountable for decisions
to you know affecting um
uh intake of students from outside of
their district
i mean we we we had no hearing on this i
mean this affects
every school district in the state
um uh uh in their decision-making
capacity
to to enroll out of district students i
mean
i i i think this is such a an enormous
change
um uh that um that that it
certainly deserves a public hearing and
you know if there's no um you know if
there's no
no uh you know deadline or timeline
um on the bill that that prohibits it
from
uh from uh necessarily have us having to
execute
uh or requires it to be exact today then
i would i would suggest that we
we open open the door uh maybe put it on
put it on a subsequent week for a
thank you mr chairman um i'll just point
out that
the section previously just mentioned
on page four d
uh it is current statute that
uh the decision of a school district
to deny enrollment uh cannot be based
on uh disability of a child that's
current statute
line right excuse me um
so all we are doing is uh adding that
the parent has the ability to appeal
that decision
which again is a current statute and
uh filing a complaint with the disrupted
commission for human rights um which is
also in statute
is an option so are you
are you suggesting that just because all
you're doing is adding stuff
to existing statute that that
transparency goes out the window and
public input
i'm not sure what uh what is
intended by public input goes out the
window
well when you're when you're when you're
when you're just dismissing
uh something is being innocuous it's
just an addition to
current statute we don't need to take
any public input
i think that's a total breakdown of the
legislative process
and and and you know denies uh granite
staters
uh their right to weigh in on um
all you're doing is
transparency in providing parents with
um what is in current statute with their
abilities under law
yeah i think you're arguing it on the
merits and i think that's fine glenn
i'm arguing the process which which i
think is about is opaque
and and does not allow public
participation
uh thank you mr chairman i'd just like
to clarify something
193 dash column 2
which ridley reference was probably a
bad reference because it doesn't exist
and repealed in
1990 so adding a 2a they're in the two
so that was probably a mistake 193.3
is the correct place to put it so
and an argument with uh what was said
before 193.2
doesn't exist then looks like oh well
that's probably messed up
it should have been in 193 and it was
covered
the bill was covered the rsa
further further discussion representing
woodside
what was coming yes that's uh
representative clark
i'll send you an email so we can get
that straight um representative
just a question i have two questions one
for representative cordelli
specific specific to the language and
the bill but
as a uh a novice in the administrative
process
i was waiting to hear from your response
from the request from
representative myla to send this to the
clerk to make sure it's relevant and you
never get back to that so i
i didn't know if you were denying his
request or this goes
it goes to the clerk afterwards i know
what the process was
well i'm going to let you know right now
i'm denying the request i see this
journey
thank you um if i may then move your
representative
uh on page
three uh
line line three through six let's talk
it's um actually it's actually line four
where it says the district in which the
student resides
i realize this is current shall pay the
tuition for the district
to the child but in the in the uh
start of the bill um it indicates that
the the tuition may be
paid for by the parent in in page 2
of that 456 area the new language h
says it may be charged to the parent um
and agreeing with the school district or
tuition so i'm trying to decide why
find out if h is accurate that the
school district must pay
why on page two lines four five and six
does the parent get
go ahead uh yes i believe on those two
sections where we add the ability
for um the parent to pay or a
payment agreement um those will lead to
approved private schools as opposed to
public schools
would you just just well representative
i mean
but isn't that contrary because on page
three it
says in current law that the district
shall pay
it's not will or may it says shall we
and then you're
saying on the on four five and six
that's contrary to the current
if i'm understanding correctly on page
three
he added if they're assigned to a public
or public academy
then the tuition payment
provisions applied in the lines of five
and six so
one for so clear it's my own mind so
that the page
two four five and six only
uh is relevant if they're going to a
private academy
and not a public school is that what you
mean
right line five it says an approved
private school
okay so that okay okay
so no there's no ratio there it's just
okay it goes that way
all right thank you for that uh
correction or understanding
uh representative yeah so you since
you've
just now given notice to denying my
request
am i correct you're denying my request
for the
clerk to intervene on a clarification of
the germaness of this particular bill
i'm saying that i'm i'm saying that
it's in my opinion that this amendment
which deals with manifest education
hardship as the internet
introduced bill does is germane i
understand that's what you're saying
i'm asking for the clerk's opinion not
your opinion you may go to the clerk
that you so desire
well i i would do that that's what i'm
requesting right now
as we're discussing this if you
if you feel it's not germany you may go
to the clerk
but i see it is jermaine
it's dealing with exactly the same topic
that we have had in the bill that was
introduced yes there was
a error in the first bill in terms of
reference to the proper statute
this is making that correction i
further discussion well i challenge the
ruling of the chair
and if i challenge the ruling of the
chair then you have to put that to a
uh i'm gonna call recess for a second
here a couple minutes and
i will uh open this up uh
okay i hope you're gonna check with the
mel do you want uh yes and we will we
will we will cover this too thank you
i'll se i'll set it up i'll send an
okay
okay we're going to go ahead and
reconvene now uh
everybody should have done their
caucuses uh
information for all those presents uh
the
clerk has ruled uh this
amendment to remain based upon the rsa
and the topic if
a member of the committee wants to
challenge the ruling
of myself you can do so
and we will then put the
that to the home of the total committee
i challenge the chair thank you okay
the challenge is is the ruling of the
chair to be upheld or uh
reject are rejected um
so i'm saying uh some emotional be
uh may i speak to my man speak to my
challenge
mr chair yes you may thank you i just
again i i don't mean to be an
obstructionist here but i do believe
that with the work that we did last year
on this bill
that included the school community
and legislators that this bill
basically changes that substantively
and i believe that it needs a hearing
that's all i'm asking for was to take
some time to have a hearing on this
to really look at it because it is a
significant bill
that um that we we have spent time on
and that's all i'm asking for rick is to
uh i'm challenge the chair because i do
believe that there needs to be
a hearing on this bill thank you
thank you okay we're gonna go ahead and
this motion is going to be called saying
that
it's a motion shall the ruling of the
chair be upheld madam clerk would you
please take the role
yes thank you it's okay
let's go get some garbage first
represented bomb yes representative
yes representative blakis yes
representative moffitt yes
representative hobson
yes representative andrus yes
representative ford yes representative
leon
yes representative soti yes
representative myler no
representative shot of respect yes
representative cornell
no representative tanner no
senator mullen no representative
no
new vlad
the amendment representative
thank you mr chair um i
i'm concerned because i know that the
school boards association
uh worked very diligently
with this house education committee
on this particular manifest hardship
and because we have this brand new
amendment that replaces the bill uh
on the day that we're executing it they
have no voice in this
uh the public has no voice in this and
i'm
i'm extremely concerned and so i would
like
um a decision from you whether or not
you would be willing to uh recess this
bill
and have a hearing at a later date
that we could have people come in like
barrett christina and actually talk
about this amendment and um how it
how it's going to actually change what
what has been done
uh and what's going on right now out in
the public schools because we have no
idea
after that bill was changed um what went
on out in the
in the public schools um i think that's
that's really important and i would like
a ruling from you whether
you would actually um entertain a motion
to
to have to recess and um
have a hearing where we could get some
input on this bill thank you
we already have a motion on the floor
representative cornelli
thank you i would just uh
indicate that the original
talk
so that was the main
focus of the amendment as well as
the placement in statute so i do not see
representative thank you representative
vlad
just just a point of cl point of
information
um this is a new new idea a new bill
and the last bill we had 126 people
uh sign into that bill of that only
four were in favor 122 of the public
were against the the bill
at a public hearing so it seemed to me
this is a pretty important bill
and since it's significantly different
we at least allow the public
since there's an overwhelming group
against it to bring back their ideas to
make this better
i think it's unfair that you you're
doing this representative
at this time i think you're hearing as
well well uh and i understand the
procedural motion
you're sitting there you can make the
you can make a ruling to retain or
recess
this bill so the public can get involved
further discussions
yes um i'm not sure why we're going on
about this the changes that are in this
bill
were presented before the public
they were put on the wrong wording of
the bill
we acknowledged that that it was a
mistake
we fixed that mistake and put it on the
current wording of the bill
so ah we didn't change the whole bill we
didn't change
anything the changes that are in here
are the changes that were in there
plus a few things that were specifically
put in
i mean we lived we had a public hearing
we listened to the comments
we made the amendment based on the
comments this is not new
this is based on the hearing that we had
already i don't know why we're going on
about this
thank you for having me thank you very
much representative
this is on amendment zero nine two
three h on path
representative uh cordelli yes
representative baum yes representative
allard
yes representative yes
president moffatt yes representative
bobson
yes representative andrus yes
representative ford yes representative
no representative cornell no
representative tanner
in the interest of transparency no
mullen no representative
yes 11 9. thank you
there will there will be a minority
sorry excuse me yes right excuse me uh
representative cordelli thank you i
would like to move my
ass as amended with 0.923
h for house bill 388.
and represent howard yes
i second the move thank you very much
further discussion
yeah i think this is a gross example of
bad government action
not seeing any more discussion
representative shaw would please call
yes this is podcast as amendment
on fl 388
represent flat i'm sorry
representative cordelli yes
representative
yes president yes representative
yes or zen moffett yes representative
hobson
yes representative andres yes
representative ford yes president
yes representative sony yes
representative miller
no representative will know no
senator shaw no representative cornell
no
representative canner absolutely not
represent allison no representative
[Music]
you 9. used to that as i said earlier
representative vlad
website luna will be doing the minority
mr chair did um oh the clerk
called the amendment as twelve eight as
well i feel like i wrote that
one um
thank you the last bill for today is hb
255 that's a bill of deals for the
limited liability businesses
for businesses and the university i call
upon represent bone promotion
and represent them off i'll second them
a rep center home do you have any
discussion
yes just briefly there's been a number
of bills and
other committees and even in the senate
on the same issue
uh and trying to get more information
from other states the problem is new
hampshire's laws are a lot different
than other states on
suing reliability and whatnot so i
recommend that we retain this
uh keep in mind that all retain bills i
believe still have to be out by november
first
so this gives us some time to see if
anything happens in new hampshire and
what
and come up with maybe language that
agreed to by all school bia and others
to what we should put in the bill thank
you
further discussion representative moffat
do you have anything representative
uh put it very well thank you uh further
discussion
not seeing any discussion with
representative john would you please
call the role
this is retained on house bill 255
representative cordelli yes president
home
allard yes representative
yes president moffitt yes
president thompson yes representative
andres
yes representative yes
representative leon yes representative
saudi
yes representative miller no
yes representative cornell no
representative tanner no representative
ellison
representative mullen no representative
white
okay that bill shall be retained
that takes us through the four bills we
had set up for today
and i believe it includes the 50 bills
which we had assigned to this committee
so with that uh we are our business for
today
yes do we have to write a blurb for a
retained or no
no no no so we're
looking for the blue rooms referencing
and 202 that's
also uh there's a majority report for
that
uh mr chair yes who's doing who's doing
the majority report on 202
that would be the maker of the motion i
believe that serves somebody on
yes okay thank you yes
and for the 203 uh
motion was made by al
allard and the minority reporter
uh by rexella mullen and for
388 uh the motion was uh
made by representative cordell he does
the majority report and robson luno does
the minority report
and the last one there is no report 255
a retained bill that's not need a report
um of the 50 bills this committee
we don't we don't need one for 202 do we
because we ital that bill yeah but
it's got to go in it's it's a motion of
itl
and it's on consent so and consent but
there's got to be
a majority report right yeah a committee
report yes
but that that is being done uh by
representation right thank you you're
welcome
so we are done those bills today um
i also want to thank all the committee
members who actively
participated on that subcommittee
to regarding the merger of the community
college system
and the university system
i do not know what's transpiring today
with finance they're
dealing with the hb2 at 10 30 which has
already
gone by um so i'm anxious to see
where they're they're going to go
tomorrow with
the decision to either
move forward as presented or to move
forward and slow down
we'll see so thank you very much and
with that
uh this meeting is adjourned